so far what's the big deal I can find
out this area I can do it exactly using
integration but my point is if I gave
you some other weird gross function and
there's lots out there we won't be able
to use this process of integration so
now I'm going to show you how to
approximate the area and we're gonna use
our exact area to make a comparison and
see if is it a good approximation or can
we do something better okay so the idea
here is I take this shape this red area
underneath the curve and I'm going to
approximate this shape using a trapezium
right way I'm gonna do it is if I take
this top point above x equals 1 and this
top point about x equals 0 if I just
join them with a straight line across
the top then what you're going to create
is something like the area that you want
not exactly but pretty close so I'm
going to show you how to do that I'm
going to borrow this trapezium that I've
already drawn up in the top corner
I'm gonna drag this one down and like I
said I'm gonna draw a line right across
the top and then I'm gonna put
everything else in the appropriate spots
like so okay so let's just zoom in and
see what I've done I have created a
trapezium which I know is not exactly
equal to the area but it'll be pretty
close right it'll certainly do a better
job than those rectangles before because
I've only got this little sliver in here
I'm just gonna highlight it another
color this little sliver in here will be
the difference okay so I've highlighted
that in yellow I know that my area is
not going to be exact but it will still
be pretty close now my question is how
do I work out the area of this purple
trapezium well think back on the area of
a trapezium this formula is one that you
haven't encountered for a while what I
have airplane mode and Wi-Fi on yeah I
don't know why I've done that anyway
that's okay what I'm doing here is I'm
going to be trying to work out using
this formula area equals H on to a plus
B I'm going to using this formula which
is the area formula for a
a trapezium and I'm gonna use that to
evaluate the area of this purple
trapezium okay thank you mrs. Lee's now
before I use this formula okay I need to
remember what the different pieces of
are cause you probably haven't dealt
with trapeziums for a while now right so
for starters let's start purple here
okay what is H mean in a trapezium well
if I go back up the top let's just use
this trapezium that I am drew around the
title H like the name suggests is the
perpendicular height right so that's
going to be let's draw it across here
this is the perpendicular height so it's
not like the leaning over it's not one
of these lengths here these are not the
height okay the height has to be
straight up and down okay so that's why
I've got this line over here on the
right hand side this is the height does
anyone remember what a and B in this
formula here for the area of a trapezium
can anyone tell me what the a and the B
actually signify and I want to go ahead
and type it in the chat top and bottom
I'll take that yeah sure
this short in the long side okay so all
of these I think I know what you're
talking about
you're referring to this side here at
the top and then this side here down the
bottom now I see Sachi you've said this
short and the long side so I think you
made that's the shorter one and that's
the longer one now le you've got basin
hypotenuse thing
I'm guessing okay so you're all on the
right track but I'm gonna say it
slightly differently for you because the
ways that you said it are slightly
dangerous or dangerous is an
exaggeration they're likely to give you
the wrong answer if you interpret things
incorrectly here's what I mean okay
when we say top and bottom right the top
happens to be on this side and this
happens to be the bottom right but the
actual thing that I need about these two
sides is that they're the parallel sides
now we tend to draw trapeziums
so the parallel sides are on the top and
the bottom but they're not always as
you're about to see with this trapezium
we're really dealing with okay so as
Joanna has said what we really want a
and B to be our the two parallel sides
this is our a we usually denote that as
a short one if there is a shorter one
and then this is
B's so when we say h we mean
perpendicular height and then when we
say a and B we mean the parallel sides
and that's really really important now
what I'm gonna do here and you'll see
why this is going to be useful later is
I'm not going to call them a and B
anymore I'm about to get rid of them and
I'm going to raise them and replace them
with something else
the reason being when we look at
integral calculus we tend to use a and B
for other things we tend to use them for
boundaries so I'm gonna stop using a and
B now I'm gonna get rid of them instead
of a and B and you'll see why I do this
in about 60 seconds I'm gonna replace
them with two different names I'm gonna
call them y1 and y2 that might sound a
bit weird where does this come from well
maybe if you're thinking ahead you'll be
able to predict Y so let's see here I've
got y1 and y2 all right so what do we
need we need for this new trapezium that
I've drawn here we need to know it's
perpendicular height and then we need to
know these two parallel sides
all right look closely let's start with
the parallel sides I think they're
easier to identify what are the parallel
sides in this trapezium going to be
because I haven't marked them in have a
think
yes Sarang will happily help you with
those questions after the lessons done
can anyone tell me which sides they will
be what direction are these parallel
sides going in yeah fantastic I'll take
that hands up thank you parent well done
so it's it's this side here and this
side over here these up and down I guess
the vertical sides right so Jana and
Tashi have said it more MORE let's see
it's not accurate but it is a more
descriptive way of saying it okay so
let's go ahead and let's mark these two
sides in as our parallel sides so this
one is quite short and this one's a bit
longer here okay so now maybe you're
starting to get a sense of why I called
these y1 and y2 where are these coming
from well they're coming from vertical
lengths in my trapezium these are going
to be going up and down so their
y-values the length of these will be y
know so I'm going to call this one y1
and I'm going to call the
one y two all right now once you've got
that hopefully this tells you you're now
gonna have to look at this trapezium
sideways so this is why top and bottom
is not the best way to describe y1 and
y2 it's about them being parallel okay
so now the only other question is if
I've got y1 and I've got Y 2 what H
where is H on this diagram can anyone
tell me where H is going to be found how
do I calculate all right Abby's got the
number well done yeah so it's the base
line excellent along the x-axis perfect
you guys are on the money okay so I'm
gonna draw across here a set of arrows
here so it's a bit weird because we
usually think of height as an up-or-down
thing right but it's a perpendicular
height it's perpendicular to the
parallel sides of this trapezium so you
can see there's a right angle here okay
so since it's a perpendicular there to
the parallel sides that's what makes
this the perpendicular height so I'm
gonna call this H so now I know what H
is I know what y1 is I don't know what
y2 is I should say I know where they are
but I actually don't know what any of
these are equal to right I don't know
any of their values so we can go ahead
and work out what each of these is
unless do it in reverse order because H
is kind of screaming out of us and I
think some people actually already said
what the answer is yes actually you said
three taking away one and I think Abby
you went straight to saying it was two
so what are we doing here and please
remember this we've got the the top
boundary here the upper boundary and to
get to we subtract this lower boundary
right so I am going to go ahead and
write like Sasha has this is three take
away 1 which is 2 okay so if I've got my
height now I've got to deal with my
parallel sides my y1 and my y2 how do I
find out what these are equal to how do
I get these vertical lengths because
they're not written anywhere on to my
onto my graph let's just start with y1
how do I work out y1 okay I am gonna do
some substitution ok Abby's on fire
today all right what am I going to
substitute and what am I gonna
substitute into can anyone tell me let's
start with the x value what x value am I
going to substitute in
okay so if I take three
that's this upper boundary over here so
if I substitute three into my function y
equals x squared I'm gonna get this
length right so if I substitute y into x
squared I'm getting three squared so
that's gonna be nine are you happy with
that I'm gonna go over we skipped y1 we
did y2 first okay so because it's
vertically above x equals one I'm going
to substitute in x equals one so I
should say that's going to be 1 squared
which equals one I actually really to be
accurate should call that 3 squared so
you know where it comes from and that's
equal to 9 all right so now I've got all
my pieces I've got the H I've got my y1
I got my y2
I'm ready to go so now I'm going to say
I'll do this in purple since I've been
doing this trapezium in purple I'm not
going to say the area equals because I
already know right from the outset that
this is not going to be exactly the area
it's just approximately close to it
right so I'm gonna say instead of area
equals I'm gonna say area is
approximately equal so I'm using these
wavy equal signs
this is not the only way you can write
it some of you might have seen an equals
signs with um dots above and below it um
you can do it that way if you prefer my
problem with that is that when I'm in an
exam and I'm writing with a pen and I'm
doing it fast my dots tend to be very
hard to see because sometimes my pens a
bit dead or something like that so if
you can't see them then it looks just
like an equal sign whereas it's much
harder to mistake these wiggly lines
here so what am I saying the area is
approximately equal to and now I'm going
to use my area of a trapezium formula
like so I've got my H I've got my y1
I've got my y2
let's substitute them in okay in fact
I'm even going to connect them over here
so let's go here's my H which is gonna
go here here's my Y what whoopsie-daisy
didn't want to drag that with me here's
my y1 which I'm going to drag here and
then lastly here's my white shoe
she's going to end up over here so ready
to substitute maybe you've already done
it I'm getting approximately equal to 2
over 2 and then I've got 1 plus 9 2 over
2 of course is 1 so I'm just getting 10
and this of course is in units square
now let's have a look at this okay this
is an approximation gianna as you said I
guess if what we had was a straight line
you would get exactly the area because
the trapezium would be exactly equal to
your function but most of the functions
we're dealing with a curvy and weird
okay especially those more challenging
ones above so yes this will always give
you an approximation